um members using devices
must move and turn off the sound to
avoid feedback
consider turning off the video if you
intend to use the keyboard for taking
notes
by the way you can thank this committee
for all these special directions
for good sound quality it is important
for members to speak clearly with some
volume soft voices may be heard
there's been some feedback from the
public and members that here
soft speakers are hard to hear the
microphones here in the room pick up
sound
very well so be careful about side
conversations
and this computer will be muted
at any breaks and please remind
me to hone you if we are muted before we
start w
representative has now been uh
designated our official computer unused
so if you're talking and he doesn't like
the pre-registration information for the
entire day is printed out 30 minutes
prior to the first hearing
if you missed the deadline you must
still register online
or your name will not be called once all
pre-registered speakers have been
touched by the class they can raise your
those are announcements particular to
this meeting
as to this meeting being held in three
wealthy
here i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as
the result of october 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and
calendar for today an executive session
to communicate previously during this
meeting through the doom
electoral committee platform and the
public has access to contemporary native
speakers and if necessary participate in
all necessary access information has
been made available
included by from our website
who knows for this meeting compliance
with house removement are at sa 911a and
anyone who has a problem and processing
the meeting should call
271 3600 or email
hcs bench.state.nh.edu
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting
the meeting will be adjourned to read
attendance when a future member states
their presence please also statement if
there is anyone in the room with you
[Music]
i am present um calling in from home and
there is no one
in the room with me at the present time
representative barry president
i thought it was madam chair i'm sorry
i'm here and i'm alone
thank you representative
good morning i am here i am alone in my
home and i just unmuted in time
hi i'm here and my son is here in
hi i'm here at my home and i'm alone
representative hayward representative
he is muted representative
i i'm here alone
representative lane i'm sorry i'm having
trouble hearing you madam chair um it's
a little garbled
um we've got the microphone over here
let me move it and see if that's a news
and representative griffin just so you
know scott kelly is coming down because
i
i had the same um sense i wasn't
positive
what was going on so he's going to come
check it out in a sec
okay um i am i am here
home
here at home with two family members in
thank you um and before we begin take
testimony from
our first sponsor i would like to
do the pledges we have done in the
election
our first bill this morning is
uh house bill 97 modifying
the dates of the state primary and
associated filing deadlines with us this
morning
to introduce the bill is sponsor
representative bong
representative owen are you with us yes
and thank you madam chair and members of
the
election law committee which was my
first committee in 2005 and 2006.
so anyway i'm ralph baume hillsborough
district 20 in the town of litchfield
we along with rhode island have the last
primary date in
the country depending on the calendar we
are desperately close to the federal
limit
as of the number of days before the
general election
luckily in the past few elections we
have not needed the recount if so we
would have had a problem
moving it up a month will get more time
for absentee ballots
to be utilized especially for the
military even the 45-day deadline for
absentee ballots makes it difficult
for military members overseas to request
a ballot from their town
and then mail it back in time a quick
shot count
shows that 16 other places have their
primary in august
and currently we have a longer primary
than
general election moving up earlier
then that will cause problems for
example to june we'll make a five-month
election cycle
this will only make elections more
expensive for candidates
and make it easy for only the rich to
win
of course the u.s postal service and
print shops will make more money as
other media
and that will cause moving the filing
date to march
forces candidates to have a total of an
eight month election cycle
and with the redistricting happening
this year
will definitely cause a problem from
past experience
experiences seriously doubt it will be
finished earlier than may
and just heard census data will be
late also no
town elections are in march in april
people need a break from elections
starts from town elections in january
then state and federal january to
november
we'll have signs up along the roads all
year
so with that uh thank you and i'll
answer any questions
thank you do members of the committee
present in the room have any questions
representative mcdonald thank you madam
chairman
representative i was just curious august
obviously
is one of the heavy summer months are
you concerned about burnout
or participation as a result of a
primary in august
not really i think it'd be better right
now we have a
problem within september it's right
after labor day and school starting
in june if we move it to june we also
have a big problem because of
of uh schools getting out and uh
and uh you know in colleges you know
people getting ready to go to college
and making the trips and whatnot so
i think august like i said 16 other
states have their primary
in august and it doesn't be a problem
and with absentee ballots of people
going on vacation
they and whatnot they can request an
absentee ballot
thank you thank you other committee
members representative for homework
thank you um
do you think this will help college
students who are making plans
to move from their
where their home is to the dormitories
to help them to vote in our state
well if they're not in the state and
they're not residents of the state at
the time of the primary which
would be any time like during the summer
yeah they wouldn't be able to vote
further questions from committee members
does any committee member participating
i'm not seeing anybody raise their hand
online representative barry do you have
a question
yes um did you mention that moving the
primary day
since june raised across the election
for
i can't hear that you said in your
your uh in your testimony that moving
the primary date to
june would raise the costs for
candidates
i'm curious how that would raise their
responses
yeah i think it would increase the cost
for anybody running for
a five-month cycle i mean it's
it's you know we constantly being
we will be bombarded and finally people
stop even listening
uh also what the big problem i see this
year
is moving it the filing date would
probably then have to be in march
we won't have to be distinctly done
before that and i've been involved
with happening two two redistricting
and it's not gonna happen by may
i mean you know before before may
and i remember 20 years ago it didn't
happen until end
toward the end of june so redistricting
i think the major concern you're going
to have to look at
because it's not going to happen before
may
it was the laptop i believe that was
creating the feedback yes
it showed my microphone was off the
whole time so i think if we have a break
i'm going to ask my tea to come to look
because i'm having a little problem
with my controls all right thank you
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for your participation this morning
thank you also signed up to speak
on this bill is limited
back and i am having a problem promoting
her
which is like when we have somebody
down if they could come on a break to
take a look at what's going on here
representative mcdonald can you promote
her please or
pam i just did it representative griffin
miss blankenbeaker welcome to the
election law committee good morning
good morning ma'am madam chair and good
morning members of the election
law committee thank you so much for
giving me the opportunity to speak today
on behalf of this bill i
am in support of this bill um
i did provide an advanced written
testimony so i hope that you guys were
able
to see that but i'll launch right in um
i have been a member of the military for
35 years and i've been a proud resident
of new hampshire
since 1993 and um i have been deployed
many many times and recalled back to
active duty and every single time i've
been deployed to recall back to active
duty i've had to
ask for an absentee ballot during
elections
because because i am a resident of new
hampshire but i'm living in other states
or
abroad and um so i'm very
very accustomed to taking the absentee
ballot i have been asking for this very
bill for many many years
um over a decade because i do feel like
that as military members we are
disenfranchised when it comes to voting
uh these short windows between primary
and general election days
even though it fits within that 45-day
federal
law we're really at 56 days and so
if the postal service is slow or if the
clerk's office is slow getting the
ballots out
or in my very own case one time i had to
have a recount and so that delayed
preparing the general ballot when there
was a recount and so
um when there are those delays
then uh the ballots don't get to us in
time and you can imagine being in a war
zone and we've been in a protracted war
now for over 17 years over in the middle
east
mail comes mail isn't always a priority
if there's other things that they have
to get there for us to be able to fight
a war
the mail is not going to be the priority
and so there can be delays in getting
our ballots to us
and so a bill such as this that would
back up the primary date so that the
um the different you know the general
ballots can be prepared
and they can be sent out a little bit
sooner will
absolutely help uh folks like us who are
deployed or out of
out of the state to deal with delays in
the postal service
and get our ballots to us and i'll just
share one little quick war story uh for
those of you don't know i
served aboard usns comfort last march um
in support of cobit relief and our ship
was docked in new york city
and on april 1st my daughter sent me a
little care package just had some easter
chocolate in it
from her home in texas to new york city
you would think that would get there
very easily
post office guaranteed delivery before
easter which fell on april 12th
the package was returned to her in
september
that was a five-month delay in the
postal service
getting a box of chocolate um here
within the united states so we can see
that there are delays in the postal
service
and i think any um length of time and
certainly this
additional month would greatly serve our
military and
you know i don't want to you know blow
our own horn here
but military members are the ones who
protect and defend the constitution for
all of us abroad and
um voting is one of our fundamental
rights and we want to be engaged in
active citizens even when we are far
away from our communities
and this is a great way for you guys to
honor our service
and ensure that our vote matters so i'm
happy to take any questions
but thank you very much for the
opportunity to share my concerns and my
support of this bill
thank you questions from committee
i'm seeing on questions from committee
if i could just interrupt could people
hear representative barry when he was
speaking
because the microphones are placed in
different positions
today well we have somebody here if
anybody if you've had problems hearing
representative berries would you let me
know
well we can hear them because we're in
the room since the microphone last week
was down there and now it's up here i
just want to make sure
it looks like people could um just to be
your representative
and you want to move that microphone and
thank you i i do have a question for you
um this that you're speaking on today
proposes
that it be moved to
tuesday in august we have some other
notes that we're hearing
today that are proposing june
september other dates to i understand
that you're in favor of
moving the primary lead do you have an
opinion as to what
um not necessarily you know i think that
uh obviously the september date is very
tight
because that only gives us about 56 days
between uh
the which is where we currently are
since september i think
august definitely gives another
opportunity especially
in the um if there is a recount
and there might be a further delay uh it
seems to be successful in other states
it's hard to say you know if that
if backing it up to june would make a
you know
more of a difference obviously we just
want more time
so at least me and and i should say
right away that i'm not speaking on
behalf of the department of defense or
the united states navy this is purely
lin testimony of lynn blankenback or not
um
you know not the united states navy um
but um you know
any any extra time you can give us would
be great
um and i i really don't have an opinion
on the merits of a june date or
or a april date or a you know a further
date i haven't done an analysis to
determine whether or not
that would be more cost effective or i
just know for me personally being in the
military that
any extra time you could give us would
be great
not seeing it thank you very much for
joining us this morning
also signed up to speak on this bill i
can tune into the branch and time of
branches and attendance if
if he or she could please raise her hand
if i don't
right and if anybody knows um mr
lebranch or perhaps you could
ask him to contact me remember to
contact me
uh because i recall that he was he or
she was signed up last week for one or
two bills and
it's not in attendance and if he wants
to participate i want to make sure that
there are no
problems is there anybody else who would
like to speak on this bill
i note that um deputy scanlan
is participating in the election on
hearing this morning as the
secretary of state's office want to
offer any testimony on this bill this
morning
he has raised his hand madam chairman
deputy scanlon
all right i think he's a participant
though
his hand is back up would you like me to
promote him this is where i'm having a
little problem
thank you definitely
people
here can you hear me madam chair um
yeah i'm having some uh some audio
issues
it might be on your end i don't know if
other people listening in or having
trouble hearing
you madam chair i can hear the people
testifying just fine
and i can hear uh pam smiling just fine
but
um you're you're you're coming across
very
difficulty here um many people
applauding but i just turned on a
microphone that have been turned off is
that better
that's much better there you go thank
you
for attention yep thank you um
i was planning on just testifying on the
bill that natalie
wells representative wells has sponsored
on our behalf but
i just it might be helpful for the
committee to know
that um the september primary has been
in place
since 1910 and the primary since then
has always been held
in the month of september we have had no
to the voters in time for them to be
able to vote in the general election
there's a federal statute that requires
that
ballots be sent to military and overseas
voters
no later than 45 days before the
election
provided the request has been made of
that voter
that statute also goes on to say that
in the case of military voters we have
to be able to
email ballots to them in other words
deliver the ballot
to the voter electronically which we
which we do and we
meet the we meet the 45-day deadline
with very few exceptions and then it's
up to the voter to
download the ballot uh mark it
and then uh return it to the city or
town clerk
in the in the in the town or city that
they live in
in the past the department of defense
has been incredibly helpful especially
when we're in a wartime situation
and we have many troops overseas
you know that are serving the country
they step up
and have collected ballots in the past
and returned them to the states
and made sure that the delivery through
the postal service was expedited
this past election cycle has been an
exception
where the the the post office has just
had
very difficult time delivering uh
mail period in a timely manner and
that seems to be an internal problem
with post office
you know whether it's a funding issue or
whether it's
an absentee issue because because of
covid
i think we all recognize that the mail
service today
is not what it was even two or three
years ago
so that is an issue that needs to be
in terms of this specific bill and an
august
date for a primary the one concern that
we would have is that
that families are generally in vacation
mode
a lot of people are taking time off from
work
and states that have moved their
primaries into
the month of august have had
have had their turnout drop in general
terms and
i think vermont is a good example
they're experimenting with
uh moving the date of their primary
earlier
uh than it had been uh they moved it to
the last week in august
uh a few years ago uh then they moved it
earlier into august
and and i'm not quite sure where they
stand at the moment but
uh trying to figure out what the what
the perfect date of holding their
primary is
at least to the state of vermont seems
to be a moving target
so with that madam chair i would be
happy to answer any questions
does anyone have any questions
representative
window
back in madam share i had
great difficulty hearing the question i
don't know if somebody could repeat it
representative yeah i'll try speaking a
little louder can you hear me better now
that's better yes so my question is
whether
or not the primaries in september or
august
would would be still be the same 45-day
window
after developing people to get their
the federal requirement is 45 days i
don't think that there is anything to
prevent us
from sending the ballots the absentee
ballots out to
military and overseas voters if they are
a golf question to know
right now what kind of rate of return we
get back from military
folks
what percentage of those ballots come
back
uh i don't have the answer to that
at the moment but let me call the people
that work in our hava office
the help america vote act office that
handles
those ballots and i'll see if i can get
that number for you
thank you today
you other members representative barry
thank you secretary of state to be here
um you said in your testimony that um
the competitiveness of the primaries in
the states
didn't just look at it as a biome itself
represent barry again i had great
is that better secretary well
without the the the extra background
so secretary can you hear me
[Music]
mr secretary can you hear me now yes
that's better
so i have a question about the study
that you cited about the primary date
moving back did that study
can include competitiveness of the
primaries in terms of turnout and what
i'm getting at is
if there's not a competitive primary
less people are voting
so correlation is not necessarily
causation and i'm wondering if the study
that you decided
incorporated that i
represent barry i don't have a specific
study it's more
thank you committee members with
questions representative providence
thank you i will try to speak clearly
and loudly for you representative
o'brien i can hear you just fine okay
uh are you aware of
other states with an august primary
and can you tell us a little bit about
the
voter turnout rates in those states and
i have a follow-up
thank you uh well
yes i mean there are states that have
august primaries
vermont is probably the closest example
and you know what i should do is compile
uh some of the data that you're
requesting in terms of you know
in those states compared to new
hampshire and i'll make an effort to do
that very
very quickly thank you follow up thank
you
this would be an anecdotal situation but
i'm i'm curious if you're aware of any
service member who has
been disenfranchised because of this
uh september primary that they missed
deadlines by just a few days
have you ever heard of such a thing
yes i mean i i i think that probably
happens in
every election where we receive military
and overseas ballots
uh after the election uh that also
happens in the general population
uh where we receive ballots absentee
ballots
uh after the fact and and we do know
that that there are service men and
women that
serve in very remote locations
you know in duty and service to the
country
and those voters do have a very
difficult time
getting their ballots back in time to be
counted
thank you representatives growing
up your secretary uh for you
having you in august of june
let me repeat the question if you can
hear me i can hear you
you had a preference as to the actual
date
as to between august and june and you're
asking asking him that keeping in mind
that the office didn't ask for either of
those dates
i i think both of those dates have have
different challenges i think
the the moving the date uh into early
august
uh is going to be competing with family
vacations
and uh and summertime activities which
may diminish
uh turnout uh moving it to june
is a little bit different because
the the filing period would be taking
place right in the middle of the
legislative session
um you know it would probably be
sometime in march i think that's the
date that's in that
legislation we're kind of starting to
talk about the next bill now but
um you know new hampshire
elects an entirely new state government
every two years
and so if there's a filing in march
after
uh uh i mean
you're elected in november you take your
seats in
december and then a little over a year
later the filing period is
beginning for the next election i mean
you tell me whether you think that's
yeah that's a good idea or not i mean i
i think that you could have a pretty
good debate on that
um where you know you're you're you're
in
full election mode before uh
halfway through the legislative session
is over in the second year of the
biennium
thank you i have another uh
more specific question regarding service
members overseas from new hampshire
uh trying to vote in the primary
elections here
email was not available
to those service members where they were
unable to obtain a ballot that was
emailed to them
because of the um area that they're in
and
yes they were unable to vote has that
ever happened
to your knowledge i cannot cite a
specific example of that happening
but i i you know just understanding
where service some service
members are deployed that i think it's
very likely that that has happened
that uh you know a member of our
military is in
such a remote location um
and you know and performing whatever the
duty is that
you know that may be highly classified
or or whatever that
it's it is probably virtually impossible
for them to
receive a ballot and return it in time
seeing none thank you deputy is there
any other member of the public that
would like to speak in regards to this
mr becker i see that um you have your
hand raised
and if you on you you should be able to
join us thank
you thank you so much for an opportunity
to speak again
um i just wanted to uh underscore
that when we're in an austere
environment we have limited to no
connectivity
and sometimes you do have internet um
for a little bit
and you can request say an email ballot
but then you know like my situation when
i was in afghanistan
we had rocket attacks all the time and
when a rocket came in it took our
internet out and it could take weeks
to get our internet back and so relying
on an internet ballot for
people in the military in an austere
environment really
is not an option for us and i don't
think that that should play
into the mix here relying on
that we do all have voter assistance
um teams for us in the military at least
in the navy we do and so they do a
really good job trying to help us
be able to vote and um
and so i appreciate all the efforts that
folks have made to help us vote but this
extended time would help us
get through those postal system lags and
you know i can speak for myself i
ordered a ballot
when i was overseas and i i never even
got it
um so i was denied my right to vote even
though i ordered the ballot
and um so i am one of those people that
can speak to that
which is why this has become so
passionate for me and why i've been
asking for decades for this uh process
to change i
also would um suggest that i know there
are 16 states that have an
august time primary but there are other
states that have much earlier primaries
and that's wildly successful for other
states and so
with only two states having a late
primary yes in rhode island
but yet 48 other states have a longer
um opportunity to
between the primary and the general i
think that that
probably is very telling that other
states have found this to be wildly
successful and
certainly successful for those of us in
the military
um and uh
you know so so i i hope that that can
get added into my testimony although it
wasn't in my written testimony thank you
thank you elizabeth
brock has her hand raised miss ruff
if you can speak you have been joined
into the panelists and if you would
welcome um
thank you i'm trying to start my video
also
um i'm just looking through this and i
i've been reading it off and on over the
last week when it was brought to my
attention
um by a friend of mine who i had worked
with
in 2016 to get a third party
presidential candidate
on our ballot in new hampshire and
so am i understanding this correctly
that this would shorten
the time that um activists or
you know citizens would be allowed to
petition to get a third party candidate
on our ballots
it does mean that the primary uh dates
in regards to candidate filings would be
to get on the ballot would be moved up i
would presume
yes ma'am chair that that is a a very
good point
um at the moment uh third-party
candidates
or uh third-party organizations that
are trying to obtain ballot status have
the year of the election to collect
their signatures
and the deadline for turning those
signatures in
to achieve that party style status is
uh it's around the date of our
september primary so uh if
the date of the primary were to change i
there would have to be a corresponding
uh provision in statute to address
the filings that are required by third
parties
um i i just wanted to make sure that it
wasn't going to shorten
the time period i mean i don't
first see myself um working on a
working to help a third party candidate
in the future
however i am a supporter of a vibrant
democracy
and sure
we have this wonderful vibrant new
hampshire
primary i've always wondered why it
wasn't more
open supportive for third-party
candidates to participate
and that's really the only comment but
thank you for taking my testimony
thank you anybody else who wanted to
speak
in regards to this matter adam chairman
i see representative lane's hand
is up thank you representative
uh yes i had a question for uh deputy
secretary of state steganon did i
understand you to say that
you email the ballots to the folks
across in the in the service
uh madam chair representative elaine
that that's correct
uh that's a federal requirement okay
that states
uh have to have to uh
to deliver the email they have to
deliver absentee ballots
to our military and overseas personnel
no later than 45 days
before the election and it is a
requirement that
uh that we have an opportunity to email
those ballots
to our military personnel if they
request that
they have the option of either
requesting just a regular ballot or
having their ballot emailed to
madam chair may i have a follow-up
please sorry i said follow-up i'm
having problems today go ahead okay
sorry it's very hard to hear you still
um
so do they have to then print the ballot
and mail it back to you or do they
send it back to you by email
they have to print the ballot on
whatever printer they have
is there anybody else here to testify
on hb-97
i'm not anyone our next hearing
this film regards to moving the primary
to the first tuesday in june
representative alexander is with us
today
and i cannot promote him to a panelist
so pam or wayne if you could do that
that would be helpful and representative
alexander
if you put on view representatives i am
yep i'm here i was just
joined in the meeting um
thank you madam chair my fellow fellow
goffstown representative that i voted
for
um for the record my name is
representative joe alexander i represent
the town of goffstown
hillsborough district six um hb 98
is relative to this date of the prime
state primary election uh much like the
last bill
um so this this would move the primary
to june
um i believe that this bill this bill is
bipartisan bill that makes the process
more democratic
um 413 days passed from the beginning of
the gop
us primary in 2000 in 2020
and between the september 8th primary
and the november 3rd general election
was just 56 days
to have such a drastic difference
between the time
spent on elections deprives general
election voters of a fully fleshed out
and nuanced campaign primary voters and
general election voters are different
universes of voters and to give our
candidates only
roughly seven weeks to speak to a
general election after spending more
than a year on their primary
inflates the role of the primary voter
in the process and diminishes the role
of the average general election voter
by moving the primary to the second
tuesday in june we'll give both
will give voters on both sides
republican and democrat plenty of time
to debate the issues
and discuss their primary elections
before uh while also giving general
election voters
more time to debate the candidates
debate the candidates before the state
when holding elections we should give
voters the most time and research to
study the candidates hold
and the differences between them having
a late primary
could possibly have a recount and that
would give only six weeks
for the nominees to fight for the
general election a win
um so like said like the last hearing
new hampshire has the second latest
primary in the nation state primary um
and our voters prove time and time
time again that they pay attention um
some have speculated that granite
staters wouldn't pay attention to a
primary election held further away from
the general
um that argument falls apart when we
recognize that we are the first the
nation
um and we have some of the highest
participation in the nation
so um long story short i think this bill
is needed i think it
makes the process more democratic and
i'd be happy to take any questions
any questions members in the room
questions from committee members
attending electronically
yes representative bergeron
thank you thank you um representative
just a question it was brought up
earlier by one of uh
another question of for the other bill
if a third party wants to get on the
ballot it has to pull nomination papers
during the calendar year in which the
election is being held
and those nomination papers have to be
submitted i believe it's one week before
the date of the primary election
so in effect your bill would shorten the
opportunity for third party candidates
or independents to get on the ballot
they only have
less than five months to collect
signatures now instead of
perhaps the nine months that they
currently have do you think
that window would need to be changed as
well to ensure that they have the same
amount of time
to get on the ballot as they currently
have
um thank you representative for the
question i don't i personally do not see
a problem with the five month window i
think it provides plenty of time
um for those third-party um candidates
get on the ballot
all right thank you further questions
from committee members attending
i'm not seeing any thank you
representative alexander for your
testimony
thank you madam chair also signed up to
speak
in regards to this bill is ken
i did see that he was in attendance
and i once again am having problems
promoting him if somebody could promote
him to an
analyst that would be terrific
would you like to do that representative
mcdonald
can you hear us mr mclean appears to
still be at a 10-day pam could you do it
oops
mr mclean you are with us here this
morning welcome
if you want mute yourself we'd be
welcome welcome your testimony
on hb98 good morning good morning
um good morning madam chair and um
committee members my name is ken mclean
i
live in derry new hampshire obviously
new hampshire
um i do fully support hb 98
i believe that changing the primary day
to a sooner date
is long overdue here in new hampshire it
is vitally important
for the general public to compare and
contrast candidates and equally
important for voter information and
this will also facilitate voters to have
more time to be engaged in issues and
views of the candidates for the general
election
having the primary in the first week of
june allows the winners to have the
summer months to share themselves with
the voters during cookouts
parades home days fairs and other warm
including the 4th of july
other considerations for this change are
national committee's endorsements
having to wait until september for
candidates to have access to national
funding for the general election
an earlier primary allows for better
distribution of funds
available alongside other states
an earlier primary allows for greater
unity in each
party for a particular candidate after a
contested primary
adding strength to the message of the
primary winner
as it stands now the primary winner has
approximately only seven weeks to
organize
for the general election for advertising
campaigning
and debating which is extremely limited
time
for voter access an earlier primary will
for all intents and purposes eliminate
the need to have candidates sign a
pledge
to support unity after the primary as
time will be permitted
after a contested primary for sides to
heal
i personally have been involved in
several campaigns for local
international office in several
states and by comparison i have
first-hand knowledge and experience that
the earlier
the primary the better voter involvement
an earlier primary allows the voter to
feel empowered with a sense of belonging
and responsibility of the issues
concerning them
as time has afforded them to learn the
thank you mr maclean does anybody have
any questions for mr mclean
anybody in the room representative
prudenhome o'brien thank you madam chair
hello mr mclean it's always great to
hear from people from derry thank you
very much for
as a candidate i always appreciate the
summer activities
going on in the area and being able to
campaign in that way such as the fourth
of july
events how would you feel about
the the primary being held in august
uh do you feel that that satisfies many
representative mclean you should still
be with us if you'd like to speak
well maybe i'm not seeing mr mclean
anymore
thank you for his testimony appearing he
is not in the meeting anymore
the next person who has sign up for this
meeting
today is represent is
mr the creator joseph lucreta are you
with us you are if you want you
um oh can you hear me welcome good
morning
good morning madam chair thank you so
much
uh my name is uh joseph laquita i am a
resident resident of merrimack new
hampshire
and here's my testimony in favor of the
house bill 98
i fully support and back the house bill
98 bill
as a young college student i aspire to
be involved in the political process
here in new hampshire as i grow and
learn
more about the political process here in
new hampshire
i have realized that a change needs to
be made
with respect to the primary date
we need a date that will work with the
voters and encourage voter engagement
more specifically
youth voter engagement during my time in
college
thus far i have noticed a significant
lack in youth participation in our local
state
and federal election process a great
many
youths lack appreciation for the primary
process
and unfortunately only become focused
for the general election as the primary
is long
arduous and crowded i strongly encourage
our state leaders
to move our primary day from september
to the first tuesday in june
by doing so we'll afford young voters in
new hampshire
the entire summer season to learn and
evaluate
two candidates and will be more inclined
to attend various events while at the
same time
enjoying the nice summer weather young
voters
are not inclined to endure the gobs of
information
about the candidates positions during a
summer primary season
but rather prefer a spirited contest
between two candidates from both
sides of the aisle i think of our
political political process
as a sports playoff but having real life
consequences
the primary is the divisional playoffs
and the general election
is the finals in the sports world
more people pay attention to the final
with more media coverage and opinion
about the participants the political
demeanor between the primary
and the general will entice more youth
involvement and we'll be much more
inclined to tune
into that final between the two teams
sounds exciting right well
this is how we excite and engage young
folks empowering
us so that we can have an impact and a
sense
of belonging i know
for a fact that our elected officials
prefer more young people to be
politically involved
and to appreciate the democratic
republic system that we have
therefore the youth in new hampshire
would be more inclined
to become better educated in politics
and even be inspired to be a part of the
next generation of leaders
by moving the primary i believe that it
will have a positive and lasting
impact on granite state youth for
generations
to come thank you very thank much
anybody have any questions for
witness in regards to house bill 98
relative to the state primary
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question can you hear me okay
uh yes sir thank you so
um you know i heard you you want a
better
candidate and the general election you
also think it's important to vet
the candidates during the primary uh
forward of the election as well and you
send defense to to get to know and
see the policy uh ideas that
i'm sorry i like clark i cut out a
little bit uh did can you speak a little
louder
okay he was in your testimony you
mentioned um
you know the different aspects of the
election my question was
in the primary do you also think it's
important to get to know the candidates
and see what their policy
uh concerned diary and ideas are or are
you only concerned once it gets to a
general court in the election well
i'm involved in the political process
through and through but i think for
more youth who are the average voter um
i think they would be more inclined to
not
like you know um engage when there's
like a primary with a ton of candidates
because to them it would just be
confusing
but just having two candidates like one
republican one democrat
they have two options right in front of
them and they know the names and they
can just get to know them more on their
issues
rather than uh just having all the kind
of the noise of the background of the
primary
and they just kind of be more focused on
themselves in a sense
um so just really simplifying it and
just having two candidates throughout
the whole entire summer
while there has where they have school
off they would more likely pay attention
to the election thank you thank you
representative sweeney thank you madam
chairman thank you mr le credit for your
testimony today
uh do you think or would you believe if
the primary were to be held in
june of the election year that would
give
political organizations on campuses in
new hampshire
more opportunities to hold election
related events
in the spring semester of the year
instead of really just having
primary and general election events on
campus in the fall semester
uh do you think that possibility for an
earlier primary and more activities
on campuses in that spring semester
could drive
more involvement on campuses when
students would otherwise not be paying
attention
yeah i i certainly think so i mean as we
move out of winter and get into the
spring months more people are outside
um you know they're walking around
playing games on on the campus yard
and we usually table for our political
organizations outside
and when we do people walk by and they
just stop by and wonder what's going on
and if they you know wonder what's going
on in politics we would tell them hey
there'll be a primary in june
you know the weather's gonna mummer and
you can look all these candidates and
then
after that you had the whole entire
summer to think about just two
you know um so we just really kind of
again kind of use the warm weather to
get people kind of excited about it
um because during the summer we work a
lot so
when we have just two candidates rather
than like a million you know
uh be simpler for us to really hone down
on the issues
thank you other questions from committee
members
i'm not seeing any questions thank you
very much for your
testimony here this morning also
to speak this morning on this bill is
william
burke um william burke is in attendance
and i am trying to promote you to be a
panelist but my little screen is going
round and around um i think you are with
us now
and if you unmute mr herr you can be
pam if you're with us can you check to
see if he is indeed with us
and on me again he i cannot unmute him
but i
have asked him electronically to unmute
he should be getting a prompt on his
screen to do that
but why he can't unmute i i can't um
okay while we're waiting for mr burke
i see that elizabeth brock
has her hand up to speak on this bill
um
i am hopeful that if you
are mute you can speak on this bill
um i'm in manchester united to see
representative bergeron for redirecting
my question
on that i put that i brought up in hb-97
miss rock we're having technical
difficulties this morning with hearing
you
i think you might actually have a bad
connection
yeah you're she's frozen and maybe if
she were to sign off and sign back into
the meeting
it might help um clear up her technical
difficulties that's the only
suggestion i have oh she seems to be
moving again
miss rob we're having difficulty with
your connection if if you could
sign um sign off and sign back in it
might be better for us to
get the connection and we'll be sure to
recognize you
you're frozen again with us thank you um
has mr burke
unmuted
he has not he has not i i've asked him
repeatedly you know through the
the zoom feature oh there he is he's
back
madam chair madam chair thank you for
your patience
and for your courtesy in this matter um
is another person speaking am i
interrupting someone
welcome go ahead mr burke
uh good morning honorable members of the
house committee on
election law i am addressing hb
98 i respectfully oppose
hb 98 as presently written and suggest
to be deemed inexpedient to legislate
without further amendment
hb 98 proposes an amendment to chapter
2 chapter 655 it interacts
with two other sections of chapter 655
as presently written
to conflict with the rights of those
other candidates
who intend to have their name placed on
the ballot for the state general
election
by means other than nomination by party
primary
as contemplated by six section 655
14a now section 655-40 states
as uh the sec deputy secretary of state
is noted
nomination papers shall be dated in the
year of the election
this sets the opening day for petition
as january the first
the second point is that section 655-43
states in paragraph one nomination
papers shall be filed with the secretary
of state no later than five o'clock pm
on the wednesday one week before the
primary
now it follows that by changing the date
of the primary from the second tuesday
in september
to the first tuesday in june the period
of time in which
such independent or alternative party
candidates might petition
is radically reduced to five months
much of which time is taken up with
inclement weather which inhibits
door-to-door petitioning
i respectfully recommend that hp 98 be
deemed inexpedient to legislate
as written and resubmitted with
revisions so
so as to amend section 655 40
and 655.43 to protect the first
amendment rights of
independent and alternative party
candidates
to participate in our general elections
ladies and gentlemen i thank you for
your time
thank you very much for your testimony
this morning and your perseverance with
us with our technical
issues questions from the committee
representative sweeney
thank you thank you madam chair uh thank
you mr burt for testifying with us today
do you see anything in the proposed
legislation of hp 98 that removes
the write-in field from the ballot in
the general election
uh what i see is instead
as written the bill inhibits
political activity by restricting the
period of time
in which such uh independent or
alternative party candidates may
circulate their petitions
and as we know from our experience in
at the last uh general election cycle
uh where circulating petitions was
inhibited
by uh the pandemic
the state had to defend litigation from
the libertarian party
to to which had the ultimately was
resolved by reducing the number of
signatures required
but nonetheless we have litigation there
and i do not
wish the taxpayers of this state to have
to pay for litigation unnecessarily
i would prefer that the bill be
uh i'm not asking regarding the
petitions my question is do you see
anything in the bill as proposed
that would remove the write-in field
from the general election ballot
i'm not seeing any questions
further questions thank you mr berg for
testifying this morning
thank you for your time ma'am take care
now if that concludes the people who
have signed up ahead of time
to speak i have a tina gilford on the
line
who has her hand up to speak on this
bill
um and i'm having
difficulty um
with the computers you know first
meeting we were pretty seamless this
meeting is not so seamless so
i apologize if somebody could uh looks
like tina gilford has been
promoted and unmuted welcome welcome
and thank you very much i'm madam chair
um so i'm here today
um you have multiple bills in front of
you um
to move the primary um i think
that after this last election cycle it
has become obvious
that the 45-day you acaba window is an
issue
um and so moving the primary makes
sense however
this moving it to june does
have a wrinkle in it that i don't know
if it would affect other towns but would
definitely affect the town of derry
so in order to file um to
be on the primary um in instances where
you would file with
the town clerk which is the state
representative race
um you would need to file between the
first wednesday in march
and the friday of the following week to
declare your candidacy
most second tuesdays
in march for us are a town election
our town clerk is closed he's
at the um polls
um and i know that that's the case in
lots of towns so now you're kind of
cutting down the number of days
that people can actually sign up and
most
state reps that are currently sitting
are either in committees legislation
voting on bills
i i really think um signing up during
march
is a really bad idea um
and with that i conclude what i have to
say very much for your testimony and
your
uh analysis of the calendar uh
representative sweeney was your hand up
no representative proof home
bryant thank you madam chair and thank
you
uh ms guilford for joining us it's
always great to hear from dairy
residents uh do i
take it that you prefer the august
date of the primary to this one
is that what is that what you um mean
personally i think august is fine we
definitely need
at least the first tuesday in september
um
you know it's kind of funny where we
have the first in the nation primary and
the last in the nation
primary basically in a presidential
cycle
we really do extend the season for
everyone um and it definitely takes a
lot of time
as an election official thank you
representative sweeney
thank you madam chair and thank you uh
for your testimony today
um i understand your opposition to the
bill based off of the filing
from the first two weeks of march if the
bill have
is to be amended to make it filing in
the last two weeks of march or the last
week of march in the first week of
april uh would you still be opposed to a
june primary date
i believe so because i think that
doesn't leave a big enough window for
people to declare their candidacy
and then actually run um i think that
makes the window too small
thank you further questions from
representative barry is uh are you aware
of any candidates who have campaigned
further questions i'm not seeing any
thank you ms gilford for joining us
today
um the last hand i see up on this matter
is mr mclean
is attempting to join us again and mr
mclean i
appear to be able to pull you to the
panel we'll see
him or representative mcdonald if you
can help me there you go mr mcdonald you
should be joining us in a minute
and mr mclean you have joined us
can you hear me now and mr mclean you
wanted to add to your testimony from
before
yeah i'm sorry i apologize for that it
just cut out on me as
middle of um my
speech here you want me just to continue
where i left off or how did you want me
to do
why don't you continue where you left
off we have an excellent clerk and we
have a record of what we already heard
from you thank you for proceeding we did
wonder why you wanted to leave us so
quickly
it just it decided to it kicked me off
for some reason i
i don't really understand what the
message was on there was some zoom error
i guess but uh
but i did submit this to um to several
people like to the uh the chair the vice
chair
um madam clerk and i submitted this
letter to
the three sponsors as well
so if you want to continue where you
left that would be great
okay um i'll be on the third paragraph
um it says i personally have been
involved in several campaigns for local
in national office in several states
and by comparison i have firsthand
knowledge and experience that the
earlier primary
the earlier the primary the better voter
involvement
an earlier primary allows the voter to
feel empowered with a sense of belonging
and responsibility of the issues
concerning them as time has afforded
them to learn the details
work them out and to have a spirited
discussion discussion with each
candidate
candidates themselves benefit from an
earlier primary as it allows them to
convalesce with the citizens more often
which will lend
to a candidate's appreciation for the
concerns of the citizens
improving his or her attachment with
them
an earlier primary allows a candidate to
have more time to travel within the
district
to reach as many voters as possible
which allows
for the citizen examination to occur to
afford them
more knowledge of the candidates i think
we all agree
that a better knowledge excuse me i
think we all agree that a better
knowledge of the issues a voter has
makes for a better informed voter
which will allow them to be part of
discussions with the candidate
that ultimately wins a later primary has
proven to make voters feel rushed to
fully understand
any candidate's position clearly
in conclusion my door knocking in voter
engagement experiences
before and after a primary have proven
to me that the citizens are much more
involved and knowledgeable about the
issues in
candidates after the primary for too
many months
before our current primary day in
september
the lack of focus by the general public
is discernible as too many candidates
and issues permeate in a process of time
only to sprint in the end in a rapid
pace disallowing voters to fully
appreciate positions
of the eventual primary winner thank you
very much
thank you mr mclean again and finishing
your testimony with us does anybody in
the room have any questions
for mr mclean representative provost
o'brien
thank you madam chair i i
previously asked this but i don't think
you heard um
and i first want to say it's great that
you're uh joining us
it's always great to have folks from
derry and i appreciate your experience
it's very interesting to me uh how do
you feel about an
august date on the
state primary do you think that would
achieve some of your same
goals
um i mean i think june would give it
more time for the summer months i'm
really focused
on the voter here um i think
for with respect to the voter that the
giving them time to uh
get to know the primary winners
especially during the summer months
when people do have leisure time and
they do have the cookouts and they do
um have more leisure discussions
in knowing who the primary winners are
at that point
uh is going to help the voters to
communicate
about what the issues are so they can
make a wise decision so
uh would august be better this september
yes but i
i really believe that june i'd like to
give it the summer months
thank you further questions from
committee members in the room
or thank thank you representative
o'brien on
video i'm not seeing any mr mclean thank
you very much for joining us again
um are any opportunities
would like to speak to this bill please
raise your hand
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to close
the public hearing
on hv 98 and we will be moving
to hb 532 537 is relative to the date of
the state primary
um and the primary sponsor will be
speaking to us
that would be our own clerk
representative wells
who will join us and um
representative wells if you want to hand
me your pack of
notes i will be happy to take over the
duties while you
um join us and introduce the bill
representative wells i think we talked
about it we're going to increase you as
our
practice person uh that if you're
introducing a bill you're going to go
down to the chair in the middle of the
room
and sit at that table she's looking at
me
right now but if you want to go down and
sit in that chair and
welcome to the world of technology
you're going to put your back to me and
welcome representative wells thank you
for sponsoring the bill
and welcome to the election law
committee
[Music]
excuse me excuse me um representative
wells i'm sorry for interrupting but i
think you'll need to move one of the
microphones to the table
yeah that one seems to yeah does this
i had to come and get the copies of
those students thank you representative
gary okay
so just general information the primary
date
is set as as being the second tuesday in
september
and it can be as early as the seventh
and this latest the fourth day
the general election is always the first
tuesday
after the first monday eight to ten
years ago the federal justice department
passed a law to the states
the uo comma ballots in order to meet
the federal
45-day requirements ballots must be
mailed the same week it's the primary
but citizens overseas these ballots not
only need to be printed
but be put in the mail or sent out by
email depending on how a person requests
it
45 days before the november general
election
in 2010 the state had a situation of
being short on time
the secretary of state's office looked
ahead and said this short time period
would happen again it usually happens
every 10 years
but this next time will be in 2032
it would not be a whole week backing up
to the 45 days to get these
yojava ballots milled out
for an example the primary is on a
tuesday they need a wednesday and
thursday to count
friday for recounts sometimes on a
saturday too
then the state needs to print mail the
yupa ballots
out the same week the state counts
ballots by first separating the counties
alphabetizing the counties then tally
the eight county races
ballots generally go out on that
saturday
so the secretary of state's office
suggests the following
keep the lords written but in the event
to meet the 45-day federal requirement
of the europa ballots to be mailed out
the same week as the primary
primary date should be moved back one
week earlier
the new hampshire state primary has
always been in september since 1910
should not change this respectfully
submitted naturally well
representative natalie wells thank you
representative does anybody have any
questions for natalie representative
derozan thank you madam chair
questions
i'm sorry representative ross um did the
secretary of state's office ask you to
hop onto this bill yes
representative wells did the question
was
sorry the answer was yes oh i didn't
hear the answers sorry
does anybody else have any questions
thank you representative wells
senator bergeron has his hand up i'm
sorry
i see your hand thank you thank you
representative wells uh just a quick
question
why do you even need an exception why
don't you just
have a bill that says the state primary
election will be held on the first
tuesday in september
so that it's consistent uh every year
i will note that deputy scanlon is
asking to speak on this bill
thank you thank you any other questions
for
thank you madam chair is there a concern
that a lack of a pattern
will can be confusing
i find patterns of dates
to be you know very important and
perhaps that's something that mr skin
address exactly
there is a there is a way the count back
is but
um i'm going to leave that to deputies
thank you thank you representative wells
any deputy scanlan you
have been devoted to a panelist welcome
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee i'm david scanlon
deputy secretary of state uh here in
support of this bill
and would like to thank representative
wells for
uh being a sponsor um
this bill i i would consider
housekeeping you know
with our statute calls for the state
primary to be on the second tuesday
in september and in most years or most
election cycles
that provides us a 10-day window
from the date of the primary within
which to certify the vote
uh have an opportunity for candidates to
request recounts
conduct those recounts uh and prepare
the ballots either
physically or electronically so that we
can meet the 45-day deadline
that occurs saturday at midnight
10 days later there are situations
every so many years it's not frequent
but it does occur
where we lose a week in that window of
time between the primary and the general
election
and what this bill does is simply allows
us
to maintain that 10-day window to get
the job done
as opposed to having three or four days
after the election
to make it happen by you know creating a
formula that
allows us to move the primary
one week earlier in september um that's
all the bill does
uh it's like i said it's it's
housekeeping it
just allows us the opportunity to get
the job done uh
doesn't move the date of the primary uh
at all beyond that
and with that i would be happy to try
and answer questions
questions
representative mcgregor thank you
uh there a reason why
you didn't just simply make
the date the first
um the first
it's just it's just keeping with
tradition of the second tuesday in
september
um uh you know it's something that we
have been able to do
um you know to do anything beyond that i
think is it
is a policy decision of the legislature
um
and that's reflected in the bills that
representative
the rare occasion that this happens and
it's happened in the past
this has only happened once in the past
and
that one that at one time was also the
first year that the 45-day deadline
was a federal requirement and
we were able to meet that deadline
at the time i believe we had to get
creative in doing that by sending out
um uh uh absentee ballots
where uh the voter uh would write in the
names
of the candidates that they wanted to
support certainly that was not ideal
uh it met the it did meet the technical
requirements
um so we were not in violation
but that's the only time that we were
faced with that situation
it may have been 2010 i have to go back
and look
but we do know that this situation or
that situation
will occur again uh in the future even
though it may be uh 10 years from now
thank you follow-up representative thank
you
thank you if either one of the last two
bills we heard
uh sort of passed then that would take
care of the
issue and this bill would not be
responded
i'm sorry madam chair i did not hear
that question
i'll speak a little louder
if either the last two bills that we
just heard
would have passed they would take care
of this issue that this bill
that's correct i mean if you pass one of
the other two bills
uh that that were heard before this one
uh
[Music]
um
thank you madam chair i'm just uh i just
wanted to note that the sound quality
out of the committee room is um is
marginal
and often in inaudible last week it was
perfect
but something's gone something must have
changed just wanted to register that so
i i'm sorry i could just barely hear you
for instance madam chair thank you
thank you pam this is problematic we
have an 11 o'clock hearing it is 11
o'clock
we're going to start that public hearing
um on time but i am
perhaps at our testimony on that
it will not be the entire half hour and
maybe we can have somebody from tech
support down here
i think in the first instance the
microphone is our problem and i'm
hearing a little echo
we've been in the room as we sit here
and i have for a
little bit so i can something else just
changes anybody else hearing a slight
echo
i will call scott kelly and he'll he'll
be there soon
okay um but we do we do have another
bill to take up
um we i am closing the hearing on hb
537 and i am opening the hearing
on hb 222
this is a bill relative to political
party access
to a list of absentee ballots um
we have attendees in
this and representative alexander
will be introducing it and
if someone can promote them to a campus
um thank you thank you madam chair um
and thank you members of the committee
um for the record my name is uh joe
alexander i'm a representative from
hillsborough district six which is the
town of goffstown
um i'm here to present hb 223 which is
relative to the political party access
to the list of absentee ballot requests
so
i believe this is a straightforward bill
that just codifies the current practice
in state law
currently only candidates for statewide
office can request a list of absentee
ballot requests
um these statewide candidates can
request the list and then designate
their respective political party as
their agent and the party can pay for
the subscription
by removing the middle man from the
process this would allow parties
themselves to have
access to absentee ballot requests via
of subscription
without having to get a sign off from a
statewide candidate
um i believe this simplifies the current
process and law and ensures that a
political party
without incumbent statewide election
official up on the ballot
in a particular election cycle can still
get absentee ballot
um subscription without having to uh be
named the agent of a primary campaign
um so i believe this just um
this this is a pretty straightforward
bill and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you questions from committee
representative thank you good morning
representative alexander
new hampshire i believe has only two
legal political parties
uh i think that at least four percent of
the vote
candidates previous election would be
the only only legal political parties
the question was there are currently two
legal political parties in the state of
new hampshire
any other entity be able to obtain a
list
um i believe any current statewide
candidate can
obtain the list but if if there is a
i mean as far as i know um if there's a
candidate that is a statewide candidate
for office
um they're allowed to obtain a list so
it doesn't matter what party or what
election
yes thank you madam chair just a
very simple question uh when the
candidates ask for
absentee ballot lists they're provided
the address of the voters who've
requested absentee ballots
your legislation doesn't ask for that um
it's
part of you know public information on
the checklist i'm just wondering
um that's that's a great question and i
welcome the committee if they would like
to add that information onto the bill
i believe the sponsors would certainly
be okay with that
for that the
representative so bill asks for the
voter id number
and most major parties have databases
of voters already obviously include
their voter id number
so yes it would probably be sparkling
bill but
it is an effective way to already
thank you further questions from
i'm not seeing any thank you
representative alexander
thank you madam chair deputy scanlon
is in attendance and would like to speak
to this bill
um and if it's worth to speak somebody
else
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record i'm david
scanlon
deputy secretary of state not taking a
position on this bill because you know
this
these are decisions that the legislature
should make but i just wanted to let
the committee know that any candidate
can go to any town clerk in their
elective district and request
the absentee ballot list
of voters that have requested an
absentee ballot or
a person bearing a notarized
letter uh representing the candidate can
obtain a list
in the case of a statewide candidate
uh that that individual or
their representative with a notarized
letter can request a subscription
from the secretary of state's office to
obtain the statewide
absentee voter list and the information
that would be provided is that
information that is in
uh house bill 223 uh the key there
is the voter id number if
if the candidate has that number then
they can match it up to all the
information that is on
the statewide centralized voter data
based checklist that they can also
obtain
for a fee the subscription fee is two
thousand dollars
for that candidate so what this bill
does is
extends the ability to obtain the
to the political parties and with that
i'd be happy to answer any questions
questions from committee members
online you want to see
your view thank you for that information
deputy scanlan
is there anyone else who would like to
speak in regards to
223 relating to the ability of voters
excuse me relating to obtaining
lists of absentee ballot as well
i'm seeing no further testimony so i'm
going to close the hearing on hb 228.2
223 our next hearing starts at 11 30
on hb 505. uh
tech support is here we're going to try
and get our technical issues the
committee room
will be going on mute and see everybody
sorry i was muted myself yes i can hear
you
i can hear you
here
yeah maybe maybe speak say a longer
sentence because i think sometimes um
it kind of cuts out over a little time
okay i'm just sliding down here at this
table
does it sound as good that sounds nice
and clear yes
how about right here in this corner this
well you know it cut out if you you said
right here in this corner and then if
you said anything after that i'm not
sure i did hear it
how about sitting right here on this
left-hand corner um
you're very fine here yeah i heard that
whole sentence
and how about the chairs microphones
that's
that's the clearest and loudest of all
did i now see
representative griffin i don't know just
there you sort of cut out
i don't know if it's moving your head or
what might be causing that microphone
because they're so we did so the
difference last week we only had the
three microphones this is
the difference right it is well you have
one
you have one two we have three which is
what we had last week
i remember being surprised that three
um yeah so we added the mics with the
chair because it's nice and
clear
so each chair has a microphone
is it possible that that microphone is
causing some
feedback with other blackboards if it's
better
no it shouldn't be called name okay have
you begun to feedback
there has been a little echo in here for
the last
20 minutes or so i think nope
not in their head when i said i'm
hannah do you hear an echo from
the room did i
not i'm not sure that i did i mean the
sound
was was definitely not great whether i
heard an echo i don't know but
scott where you were talking just there
that that corner that left hand corner
of the table
and representative griffin is not a
hundred percent clear
all the time you know you were when you
were at her mic but i don't know
that was a clearly brief little can you
hear me though exactly
so if it's going on for any prolonged
period you're having problems with it
well just what you said there i think
you really need to um
never turn your head but it's hard for
me to see if you are turning your head
just there
you sounded fine but um a little while
ago
and it does seem as though it could be
um what about if you just take this away
we try to do can you hear from the other
mics
all right but i'm not hearing committee
members and they actually do more
do
this one seemed to be working it was the
ones on this side of the room that we
were having problems with
right now i'm hearing representative
griffin very well and i'm not hearing
go ahead and say something more okay
over here
for uh if maybe just keep talking
i'm sitting over here on the left side
of the room
yeah that sounds fine that sounds fine
but there are two microphones over here
now
so so what happens when you go over to
where representative
berry is or where natalie was testified
well she didn't have a microphone when
she first sat down at the testifying
table but then when she did have one she
but it was interesting when somebody
moved the mic and spoke
you could really hear the mic picking it
up
but when someone was moving the other
mic and moving it it was
it was no longer strong
yes yeah i'm getting i'm getting
comments that the the mic on your side
of the room
i'm getting helpful comments from others
out in the
how about now then oh that sounds much
better
how about this corner here that's nice
yes
scott when i joined this it asks me if i
want to join with computer audio
and i think as far as i know i've been
turned off the whole time is there any
now if it matters that conversation on
the left-hand side of the room is very
garbled
[Music]
griffin i have made you a co-host and i
don't know if you have um
regained your so we'll see how it goes
it seems to be responding much better
there's a lot of time to everything
today that was not happening last week
i wonder if this system just with the
more
committee meetings going on is having
like problems
i can but that side of the room is not
good it's i mean i guess maybe because
of the other conversation
i'm getting the word that you're you're
not loud on the mic in the center table
um it's difficult with the other
conversation i can hear you
but i i'm hearing that garbled
conversation behind you so it's kind of
kind of confusing
it's not great it's it's light and a
um
i'm picking up other conversations more
than you you're you're you're faint
i have a clear voice do you want me to
you're just you were just cutting out at
the mic i don't know if it's because you
were moving
so i'm over here in the conference room
checking the sound
and i'm trying to see if i'm coming
i hear you it's not really loud and
clear
but i hear the mic by representative
rosian to see if you can pick me up here
i don't know much louder much clearer
that's much
better than mikey microphone
this is this is softer than the the
tarosian mic
this this seems to be lower but i can
hear you
so but you could hear me
yes i could i can hear you
that is not good sitting at the
you are you are cutting out you are not
good there on the the left
my left hand side of the room as i move
up here um
if representative mooney moved up here
would you be able to hear her
yes that would that's an excellent spot
right there that's a good standard
mike's going of course the chairs mike
is up there
so once again we're back to this room
this side seems to be a little clearer
and the other side is having problems
um so yeah erosion mike was good
um and the the prudent o'brien maybe
mike was good but the barry mike um was
not so good
all right and i'm over here and now i'm
probably being
picked up by the cheers lincoln can you
hear me now in front of the chairs mike
yes i can sure
all right the next i might wait pam
representative abramson said he would be
a few minutes late for the 11 30
he was going to introduce it
[Music]
representative abramson for 505.
he's the sponsor the other sponsor isn't
so who do i talk to for my little name
tag
huh who do i talk to you have my name
i know you should have an eighth time
around somebody throw mine away for two
years
we're aware of the nameplate issue it's
just that it hasn't
been a top priority um but it will be
done
and it's they probably have the old ones
and some
feel right they're all we do definitely
keep them from previous years
um but they're as you can imagine there
are a lot of them
ah
foreign
and then we'll go back to mute thank you
everybody it is 11
30 and we are scheduled to begin 505.
we will be delaying this approximately
five minutes the prime sponsor
of the legislation who was going to
introduce it
um contacted me to say he had to
introduce another bill
so we will give it another few minutes i
will note if anybody's listening to this
um that i do not have the closed sponsor
signed up to speak on this bill so if no
one shows up i'm not quite sure where
the committee is going to go with this
bill
thank you and you want to meet us we'll
also
this the house committee on election law
has reconvened
um this is an 11 30 hearing uh we're
starting a little late unfortunately
representative
abramson has obviously not been able to
clear his schedule from
his testimony before another committee
um i welcome
representative terozian for introducing
bill 505 welcome representative terozio
thank you very much representative
roseanne um
in attendance we have individuals who
have
signed up to speak on this bill um
and i'm going to proceed to do that
represent
former representative dan mcguire has
signed up to speak on this bill
and promote it to a panelist
welcome mr mcguire
thank you thank you very much madam
chair members of the committee for the
record my name is dan mcguire and i'm
from
epsom and uh if i had known you were
going to put me on video and not just
audio i would have put on a tie
i apologize um
so uh i i'm happy to kick this off
because i was the
i was a member of the house from 2011 to
and i was the first prime sponsor of a
bill very similar to this
um during that time so i'm very familiar
with the issue and i
can answer questions that you may have
um
so this is one of the very what i assume
is the very few
uh completely non-partisan bills that
your committee
will deal with this is not uh does not
give
any particular advantage to any
particular party
um it's it's an idea that just improves
the experience of the voters
and in particular it makes sure that
every vote
counts that that every voters uh
what they want to have happen is
expressed and
and is part of the becomes part of the
count
um it is it's the bill is very simple
it doesn't require any new the structure
of the ballot doesn't change the
machines don't change the accounting
procedure doesn't change
if you look at the bill it's extremely
short uh the only thing that changes
slightly
are the instructions that are written on
the ballot
so to give you an example of what
the bill would do um
and and the other thing is it doesn't it
it really doesn't make
a difference in any kind of head-to-head
race uh you know if you have race for
governor and there are two people
running
this makes no difference there's no
change in the
effect of this bill it is
it is uh makes a slight difference in in
races where
uh multiple people are running sometimes
for multiple seats
or it could simply be multiple people
running for one seat
so um to to illustrate what the bill
does
let me talk about my the district that i
represented
when i was in the house and that's a
district of two towns epsom in
pittsfield
and had two reps in those for those two
towns
um currently this is uh representative
allard and close
are the are your representatives from
this particular district
and um so typically there before
in the general election there before
candidates uh two democrats and two
republicans for these two seats
and uh let's consider the ways that
voters might vote for these
for these four candidates so first of
all someone can skip this
this election all together right they
could leave it blank
we don't have any problem now doing that
uh more
more typically people vote for two of
the candidates
um often they vote for the same party
but not always sometimes they might pick
one from each party
so uh this this um
bill doesn't change that in any way um
what about if someone votes for a single
candidate
right so they pick one out of the four
this this
uh bill doesn't change that in any way
and this is not that uncommon i mean we
even have a name for that we call that
bullet voting
and and it's currently perfectly
acceptable it would be acceptable
uh nothing would change if this bill
passed
similarly um let's suppose somebody for
whatever
reason they might have they voted for
all four candidates
well currently we don't count that right
we
we throw that out and say that's an
overvote you can't do that
um but supposing we did count it which
would happen under this bill
it wouldn't affect the outcome in any
way right because a vote
there are four candidates and a vote for
all four
everybody's vote goes up by one it
doesn't change the outcome
but the only thing that would change is
let's suppose that someone voted for
three
of the four candidates now currently
that gets thrown out right we call that
an overvote
and and that person's vote is not
counted
but it's clear to anyone looking at that
vote and looking at the ballot what that
person is trying to it to express
right that person who voted for three
out of four
says i don't want number four right i'm
i'm voting against
number four i dislike number four and i
don't care
between the other three and so what this
bill would do
is say let's count that that's a
perfectly valid
uh sentiment a voter can easily think
uh this is a person i don't like and and
want to vote against them
and doesn't want to express an opinion
among others
right there's no there's nothing
theoretically wrong with counting that
vote there's nothing practically wrong
with with counting that vote
it's exactly the same thing as a bullet
vote and i wish i had a good
name for it like bullet vote i don't
know what you would call it i'm not that
great at marketing
just you know voting against one person
would essentially is is exactly the same
as voting for
one person in such a circumstance right
and there's no reason why we shouldn't
count that and we shouldn't
um listen to what that voter
wants to say and so that's what this
bill does this bill says
we should count that kind of vote right
there's
it eliminates over voting and it it
listens to every voter
now i actually and i recommend this
really to all of you on the election
committee
is is to participate in a wreak and
recounts
and look at ballots because you learn a
lot about voting
simply observing ballots and i once
observed the situation in a
that was similar to what i just
described and that was
um i was in i was watching a recount for
state rep in hudson hudson pelham
this is a huge district i think there
are 13 reps in that district
and it was they had a close election and
and so
it was being recounted and we came upon
a ballot
where someone had voted for for every
single democrat on the ballot it voted
straight party line all the democrats
but when it came to
state rep they had voted for all the
democratic state reps
but they had also voted for one
republican
right and so what happened was
that ballot was thrown out when it was
absolutely clear to every single person
looking at that ballot what did this
voter
you know what was in this voter's mind
because clearly this voter was a
democrat and wanted democrats to win
but in the case of state rep they were
maybe friends with or neighbors with or
knew one particular republican candidate
and they liked that person too you know
this perfectly human sentiment it's
important
and why not let them express that so
that's what this
uh that's what this uh procedure this
this bill house bill 505 would do
i highly recommend that you vote it off
yes and i'm happy to answer questions
thank you questions from committee
members
thank you representative mcdonald thank
you mr chairman
good morning mr um
i've sat in on a number of recounts over
the years as
you've indicated you have and in
multi-candidate field the tabulation is
always a challenge
you know you're going through that um do
you
want to see additional tabulating
problems counting problems
initially with this uh this proposed
system
can you hear me yes i can hear you and
and thank you very much
representative mcdonald and welcome to
the house you might say
because i know this is your first term
i don't think so the answer is no i mean
first of all the same machine that
counts votes
currently and and um would simply be
programmed
not to throw out overvotes right it
would just count every
every mark on the ballot and so
the machine is no different many places
use machines
in cases where they don't use machines
and they just do thick marks like you do
in a recount
they would simply keep basically read
off all the names and make the tick
marks in the
in the appropriate places and so i i
don't foresee any any real difference
thank you thank you questions from
committee members in the room
representative thank you madam chair
thank you uh
for taking my question
so you know i heard your testimony that
if
you know you vote for three of the four
you're obviously
making it known that that one candidate
you didn't vote for
is um you're voting against that person
but but under the present
system you can still do that you just
can't vote for as many people but you
could still
vote in essence not for that
candidate so i'm a little i don't quite
completely follow what
what the goal is here to to me this
almost seems a little bit like ranked
voting i know you don't get a chance
it's not a run-off but
so maybe you can clarify a little bit
more for me how that how that would make
a difference between whether you voted
for two people when you were voting
against somebody you voted for three to
vote
vote against them um thank you very much
for the question representative
so let's let's take your particular
example
i want to vote against number four and i
have no preference between one two and
three
in the current system it's up to me
to try to guess which ones of one two
and three
will be the most popular and vote for
those two
right so i have to guess that that the
voters
are are gonna like one and two better
than they like three
right so that i can i can
make my vote um work
basically so so the voter is required to
somehow
have a handle on the election and
and make that choice and i don't know
how a voter necessarily knows those kind
of things
um and so so the voter who wants to vote
against four
can't just express that they have to
vote against for
and against somebody else right and and
the
the most practical thing that they
should do is
figure out which somebody else is least
likely to win
and vote against them you know because
they're they're trying to make sure
four doesn't win but they're gonna have
to do the same thing to three
and so why should the voter be required
to
do that the voter who wants to bullet
vote one person
um doesn't have to do that they can
easily express what they want to express
but the vote voter who wants to sort of
bullet against one person
can't express that and i think it's a
perfectly
natural thing that a voter might want to
do i
i've done it myself sometimes um
so so that that's it your
current system requires the voter to
kind of
be politically aware in a way that that
doesn't make sense
thank you follow-up representative thank
you madam chair
if all of this so if i hear it correctly
it's it sort of gives the voter
a chance to second guess um
in in essence he's he's voting more just
against that person than he is
necessarily trying to vote for the the
two
best people out of the four is that am i
um yes thank you for the question so
again
i'm i'm postulating we have a voter
who really hates one one particular
candidate would not want to see that
person win
but among the other three they're okay
they don't um
they don't have a strong preference
right
and so you might say well just pick two
you know what find your two favorites
you may not have a big preference but
why not just vote for them
but but if by doing that you allow
a candidate number four you know because
you didn't vote for three
candidate four beat number three
well now you're unhappy you see what i
mean
so so it's it's makes it tough for that
voter
to to express what they want to express
and have it count
and there's no reason for it i mean
i guess i don't see an objection to this
procedure
right um other than it's not you know
it's not the way we've always done it
you know that's that's the only
the only thing we're trying to overcome
here
further questions from committee members
in the room
i see a panelist has a handout uh
representative hamlet
do you have a question yes thank you
madam chair
um so representative mcguire um does
this system
guarantee that the winner will get over
of the vote so i'm trying to understand
the difference between
this system and ranked choice voting
whereas in ranked choice voting
i think it it guarantees that the winner
will get
you know a majority or over 50 percent
of the vote so does this system
assure that the winner would get over 50
well thank you for the question uh
representative
and in my little example of two people
running for four
seats of course that's true um
but in but in let's say
let's take something more bigger like
like the presidential primary
you've got 24 people running for one
position
you see in in that case um
the answer is no right because because
the winner is frequently somebody with
30 of the votes or something like that
so the only reason that rank choice
voting
creates what you called the somebody got
is because it starts to throw away votes
right
somebody liked somebody who was got a
very small vote
well they changed that vote into uh
a different preference right so so so
they keep throwing away
candidates until somebody gets 50 but
this just simply counts and um if you
took something like the presidential
primary
uh it may be that the the winner gets 50
but not necessarily thank you further
questions from committee members
i'm not seeing anything thank you very
much for your for your testimony is
representative abramson outside the
whole
representative yes thank you manager
welcome the bill has been introduced and
representative mcguire spoke to it if
you can sit in that chair that's where
we're having people
speak
um do you want me to grab a microphone
no
a member of the committee my name is
representative maxie
representing hampton hampton falls in
sieber
uh introducing housewell 505 which is
called approval voting but it's just
kind of a
it's a big fight or work for we don't
throughout speed battle
i come from seabrook and i felt folks
learned to vote the first time and
uh i just sat down at a table just like
this at seaworld town hall and women
only voted for trump and she
voted for trump but she also marked the
write-in
and was trying to write his name in and
she had never done it before didn't
understand the process
um so she was having a little bit
difficult time and i thought
um you know what's going to happen if
you go to the rebound
the presidential election wasn't imposed
in new hampshire but
what if you had a legislative race where
people did not quite understand the
process we do have quite a few voters
over voters and younger voters who are
voting for the first time
and when you cast a ballot as a citizen
the way i see it is you own your value
your ballot belongs to you
and you have an absolute legal moral and
constitutional right to
mark your preferences the way you want
so many of the local races
that we have in seabrook are five
candidates running for two planning
boards for
four uh candidates running for one
selection
where we have we have multi-member
districts one race
uh i come from terms of material we
actually
so we've looked at instant run off
voting right choice voting and some of
the other options
and they do those who run into problems
when you have
multi-member districts and especially if
you have uh you know going for two seats
or three seats and you have
quadrant control and if somebody does
i've heard this before if somebody does
just want to vote against an incompetent
selectmen and vote for the other three
candidates
they should have the right to do so but
most of what approval voting does
is just say if somebody marked their
ballot
uh twice for free candidates right now
we counted um under approval voting if
they mark three
three candidates for two seats uh
right now that could still amount your
whole ballot gets done
on recounting throughout the entire
ballot and that point has been
disenfranchised
under approval voting we don't do that
we count every single vote
one of the concerns that was brought up
in the majority report
last time we brought this up the skills
we brought up twice to report
the concern was might have people
getting elected who didn't have
more than 51 of the votes but uh
but that's actually a bigger problem
right now uh most members of the house
of representatives right now didn't mend
the doors especially
not for multi-member districts uh some
actually
uh less than 40 percent of the vote um
but they were
going for three seats and you know they
got 39 percent
and the next candidate down about 36
the approval voting is much more useful
for multi-member districts four-way
selection periods
uh complicated bond issues uh something
that needs to be
resolved sometimes with serving on
municipal county and
in the town of captain falls the school
board put on i believe it was a 5
million dollar bond
for the school district and by citizen's
petition some people said that was
enough so they wanted to do the full 7.5
million dollars
because both of them were on the ballot
at the same time they both failed
neither got 60 percent if they needed
uh pass and they had to come back and do
it again
the subsequent year ended up costing
approval voting is the only it's the
only alternative voting method that's
actually simpler
it doesn't require any new software or
hardware
continues in the same standing devices
it's easier to figure out what the
intent of the voter was
compared to all the other methods even
the current method
from st louis fargo have had
very good success with approval voting
some members of this committee who were
here a couple of years ago said
they wanted to see how other towns
rolled out and make sure that the
process was working
i understand the logic behind that
there's going to be a potential lawsuit
recount or somebody who speaks something
you want somebody else to spend money
first
and finally approval voting is very
useful if you have independent
candidates third party
uh i think that it's a foregone
conclusion that the libertarian party is
going to be on the ballot again
they have been almost every year for 25
that the constitution party the patriot
party
uh another party is cooking on those
those voters who uh you could have a
constitution party candidate in your
race and you had a three-way race
those voters who know you maybe want to
make a statement
but they'd like to vote for you also if
they're voting for the third-party
candidate
uh
[Music]
our responsibility is is to protect
their
constitutional rights freedom freedom of
religion
your right to address the jury of your
as um fundamental right to mark your
ballot how you choose
our job is just to tally the votes as
accurately as
we can and make sure as the constitution
requires
and it's represented democracy requires
it whoever the top vote getter is
whoever actually accumulates the most
folks
um will this lead to tactical voting i
would say the opposite
i i see a lot more tactical voting i
talk to a lot more voters who vote
either against the republicans or
democrats or against candidates we don't
like
quite a few uh republicans who voted
they really didn't mind fighting repairs
and they voted for them
so first pass the post that you have
right now
always states the tax for voting like 80
percent of what this announces
representatives
i'm seeing questions from committee
i'm not seeing any hands thank you very
much mr
representative
also signed up to speak on this bill
today
so i'm aaron hamlin i'm speaking on my
own behalf but i'm also the executive
director for the center for election
science
we've been around for 10 years we've
also been responsible with
working with communities across the
united states and implementing approval
voting
we worked with if you can clarify for me
are you speaking for yourself or for an
organization
i'm speaking on my own behalf okay so
why don't you proceed with the testimony
thank you okay so approval voting has
been used
has been implemented in two cities um
most recently st
louis missouri and prior to that fargo
north dakota
and fargo north dakota was actually used
in a two-seat election
in prior years fargo had seen elections
where
the winner would be lucky to get 30 uh
in this past election
uh the two winners in that election uh
got 55 percent approval for one
and 51 percent approval for the other
so one of the benefits of approval
voting is it allows
uh winners to lead with a mandate
whereas previously they may have
also approval voting really is what it's
doing is it's removing an
artificial limitation of requiring
voters to choose one candidate or to
choose as many candidates
as there are seats to be filled and
there's really no rational reason for
doing that at limiting
a voter's expression all it's really
doing
is encouraging polarization uh in the
zero-sum game where it's saying choose
this party or choose the other party
rather than allowing voters to
compromise which would
encourage more consensus winners which
is what
approval voting does leading towards
those more consensus winners
also across the across new hampshire um
we're seeing a number of third parties
run this is not new
seen it for a long time also seen it in
the presidential race
approval voting addresses and solves the
spoiler problem
by allowing voters to choose as many
candidates as they want
so if they want to choose you too in
addition to say a third party or a
libertarian candidate
they can do that there's there's no
issue with that it's a
it's a very fair way of doing that by
not taking away their expression while
at the same time making sure that
they're not forced to split the vote
between you and a third-party candidate
also it's important for primaries so
when you have a crowded field in
primaries in particular
what can happen is you can have a number
of candidates in the middle who split
their vote
and as a consequence you can have more
extreme candidates win
as a result approval voting allows
voters to choose
multiple of those candidates so those
candidates in the center don't split
their vote and we have
a much more representative nominee
for that and overall we're talking about
a voting method that is
uh virtually free i just have some
education
uh component which uh the organization i
i've been with they've been great about
working with cities throughout the us
after they've
implemented approval voting and doing
the education campaign
and it's something that is incredibly
simple we're really just talking about
the language
difference within the ballot itself but
i've
looked at this issue for this is
my profession so i'm also happy to take
any questions
and address any concerns that you have
thank you so much
thank you does anybody in the room
have any questions for mr hamlin
representative o'brien thank you
thank you mr hamlin are you aware of any
increase in voter turnout since this
method has been
employed in fargo and in saint louis
the the issue of voter turnout is
something that is challenging to be able
to determine so like if we're trying to
look at like the difference between uh
two groups like
uh one uh pre-approval voting and then
post-approval voting
we've seen one election so far so it's
difficult to extrapolate from that
individual election particularly
given that that election took place
during the middle of a pandemic
so there's not really a good comparison
thank you any further questions from mr
helen from people in the room
how about from committee members who are
attending
i'm not seeing any hands so thank you
very much mr hamlin for your
participation today
have to speak on this bill is alvin c
and i can't get back to my attendee list
and i know i've seen him there so if
camera representative mcdonald could
promote him
to a panelist mr c you were with us
thank you
good morning we're good afternoon uh
good afternoon thank you this is alvin c
and uh um
sorry i don't have the video up but
you should be able to hear me now i hope
we can hear you thank you okay
um i'm alvin c i'm from loudoun new
hampshire
and i am in support of house bill
505 this is a concept
as was explained before that's also
known as approval voting
and i like the idea that it
allows the voter to better express their
opinion of all the candidates for any
the plurality voting that we currently
have
is essentially only works right when
there's only two candidates
uh then you're just choosing one or the
other as soon as there's more than two
candidates then then the approval
and the plurality voting starts to break
down
so with the being able to to do this
concept as presented in this bill
um essentially all we're doing is
ignoring overvotes or the
term and it makes it easier to program
the uh
accuvope machines because they don't
have to program in the number for
that constitutes uh overvote
um i think the approval voting will show
its best in the presidential primary
where we usually have a field of about
30 candidates
in either party even this past
presidential primary on the republican
side there were 17 candidates
in spite of the strength of
this still works
and if you think of a presidential
primary
there's often several candidates that
you can
say hey these are these are guys that i
think might be
who i want for president um
and it's not unusual to find that right
after our primary or sometimes even
before our primary
that your favorite candidate has
suddenly suspended his campaign
so at least in this case you would have
been able to
vote for several of them if there were
several that you
thought were okay you would have
supported one of those candidates
and also in the presidential primary
which is
unique in one way in that we're not
directly
deciding who's going to be on the
november ballot
what we're doing is uh determining the
allocation of delegates to the party's
national conventions
and also
we're providing useful information to
all the other states that have yet to do
one thing about the presidential primary
the text for this bill should be amended
to include the same
provisions to be applied to rsa
656 colon 31 which deals with
presidential primaries
separate from all the statewide races
approval voting also can work in the
nonpartisan municipal elections
in that the approval voting can handle
full ballots so it actually eliminates
the need to have a primary election
to reduce the number of votes down to
two candidates for a one-person office
or
to twice the number of of candidates as
there are seats to be filled
um just by that by virtue of that the
municipalities can save some uh
much needed money just by not having to
i did send an email to the many members
and i
on line five and six where the new i
would uh
where the new text says vote for one or
more
add an additional sentence blank will be
elected so that
the voters know how many people are
going to be elected for that
even though they you know they may be
voting for three and there's only two
going to be elected
um that also
um oh on line 21
after the phrase uh of
your choice or choices add the sentence
you may vote for
more than the number of candidates to be
elected that's under the instructions on
the ballot
those two changes need to also be
applied to
rsa 656 colon 31 for the presidential
primary which was missed in the original
build text
a small actually non-germane but helpful
amendment
would be in the middle of line five to
leak the words
small but for the text size when it's
describing
the sentence on the ballot that tells
i've noticed that i often hear
people mention that the we have an aging
having small type is not a good thing to
have there that also applies to the in
the line 31.
and i would like to
comment to a question that uh
representing hamlet had asked about the
guaranteeing that there would be a
candidate would receive 50
this does not guarantee that candidate
will receive 50 percent
you could have two people receive 49
but uh it also can happen
that you can have more than one
candidate have
greater than 50 um
and that was mentioned in that
question was uh rank choice voting
does not necessarily guarantee greater
than 50 percent
it's looking for that but once you get
through all the
rankings if somebody still doesn't have
greater than 50
and also
on the uh just to remember
the constitution our state constitution
for the offices of senate
governor and executive council
specifically now use the word plurality
for the election that was approved in
constitutional convention although they
left the wording
in the sentences now rather poorly
structured
i would think that it might be worth
having a
legal opinion that
this change in the voting would not
uh affect that uh
constitutional provisions and that's uh
part second of the constitution article
uh
33 and 34 for the
senate uh article 42 for the governor
and article 61 for
the council i'd be happy to answer any
questions if there are any
thank you very much mr c does anybody in
the committee room have any questions
for mr c
i'm not seeing any does anybody
attending remotely from the committee
i'm not seeing anybody and i'm not
seeing anybody with their hand up thank
you very much mr c for testifying this
week
on this bill also signed up to speak on
this bill tonight
is mr geshman i hope you're pronouncing
that
um he has been promoted to a panelist
and hopefully has been unmuted mr
geshman
mr dutchman are you with us ma'am can
you find him mr gushman can you raise
your hand
i think he just came in there he is mr
dutchman welcome
if you can unmute yourself you are with
us
thank you very much ma'am and i am
unmuted and
madame chairman uh election law
commembers
for the record my name is ted mcgeechman
and i'm here representing myself
i am very much in favor of house bill
and i only want to point out two points
that might not be intuitively obvious to
the committee members
the first is that it is only when you
allow
voters to freely support all the
candidates they want
that you can actually tell the level of
support
all the candidates have and you don't
currently
have that today the election
committee members the representatives
what the voters really want
they are fully capable of designing a
political platform
that aligns completely with what the
voters desire
but because of the election system
that you currently have voters
will split votes between like-minded
candidates
leaving the possibility that a less
desired candidate or a less desired
platform
could win the election the second point
i wanted to bring up is the idea i'd
like you to consider
a single seat election but with multiple
candidates
more than two at least currently today
a voter only is allowed to provide one
point of
input which candidate do they want
the system does not know what they think
of any of those other candidates it
could be three it could be four
it has no idea that lack of knowledge
goes into determining who wins the
election
in contrast in an hb
505 type election what would happen
is that the even if a
voter only selected one candidate
because they could choose the other ones
they are sending a deliberate message
that they
do not want to support those other
candidates so in other words
every voter has an input on every single
candidate and because all of that
information is used
to determine the winner the result of
every 505 election will give you
the most approved of candidate every
single time
it'll give you the most approved of
lists of candidates
every single time more information into
the system
more power for the voter you get a
better result
hb 505 is a simple
and easy to understand modification to
the election rules
however provides a lot more power to the
voters
it ensures the most approved of
candidates win
and it provides to you the current
elected officials
greater and more robust political
support
505 is a powerful and smart initiative
thank you thank you very much for your
testimony this morning does anybody in
the committee room have any questions
to the witness does anybody online have
any questions
representative or brian thank you thank
you madam chair mr dashman are you
no ma'am i am not a new hampshire i'm
sorry madam chair
i am not a new hampshire resident but i
am a citizen of the united states and i
am a recently retired navy commander and
in my last tour
i served over in the yukon headquarters
working directly with our allies and our
partners
overseas and i can tell you from
personal experience how easy it is
for our adversaries to exploit the
cracks
within our political parties and between
our political parties
if all of the states were to enact the
legislation that you are currently
considering
we would have a far much a far much more
safer country and more robust against
these malign
influences of these adversary countries
who would like
nothing more than to see us dissolve
from an uncivil war
further questions did i
mr geshman perhaps i'm confused the
representative
asked if you were a resident of new
hampshire you said you were not what
state are you a resident of
i am a resident of the state of nevada
madam chairman
witness
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for joining us this morning
also signed up to speak on this bill is
mr cape
um mr k
welcome to the election law committee
this morning um
welcome for your testimony on hb 505.
thank you so much for having me and
allowing me to speak
i am a new hampshire resident i
went to school in whitefield new
hampshire and i attend
dartmouth college so i would like to say
that approval voting
is a marginal improvement within our
system with marginal cost
but i think what's not been quite so
discussed here
is the fact that it doesn't have an
ordinal component that you are not able
to see
the difference uh between candidates as
far as rankings go
so while they've said that if you do not
approve
of a specific candidate you might
approve of all the others
and vote such a way and that can be
useful
but in other voting systems uh including
ranked choice voting
that by giving an ordinal uh account
uh ranking of some sort you can more
fully
see the spectrum of support that
candidates have in comparison
to approval voting it's also worth
noting
that when discussing approval voting
there is a high level albeit not as high
as a plurality vote
that we currently have both within the
bloc system and not within the bloc
system of strategic voting
where if two candidates who i might
approve of
are net connect with each other if i'm
being strategic
i will not vote for the second place
like the neck and neck person
i'll go with my favorite choice not
showing my approval for the other person
so that i can strategically vote to get
my preferred candidate ahead
while i might have approved of both
and different systems can account for
that
that is not accounted for within an
approval
voting system um approval voting
as was said earlier does not ensure a
majority
it does not really give an extra claim
to
doing too much to get a majority it's
showing the percent of voters who
approve of a candidate
which can be useful information but it's
not a
percentage of the vote and it does not
give
good information on preference
on ranking as opposed to a binary
of i can live with them or i can't live
with them
it's distinct from ranked choice voting
and i can talk more about ranked choice
voting
um if people are interested in the
differences
and i'll be happy to take questions if
anyone has any
thank you thank you for appearing for us
again this week
members of the committee president in
the room any questions
members of the committee online any
i'm not seeing any thank you for joining
us
um is there anybody else in attendance
who would like to speak in regards to
this bill
raise your hand um
mr cobb and i'm going to ask since we
have gone over the time and you did not
um sign up to speak oh you you have
signed up but not supposedly speaking
i'm gonna ask that you
keep your testimony to three minutes um
you have welcome
if somebody could i i'm having a hard
time elevating mr cobb for some reason
if somebody could elevate him
he's on the attendees there we go
mr cobb you were with us if you put on
you
okay how about now yes thank you mr cobb
please
okay yeah good afternoon madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
stephen cobb
and i've already submitted written
testimony into the record but i thought
i should summarize a couple key points
also i could address the points about
irv the the ranked choice voting that
were raised recently if you have
questions about that
so my my testimony took the form of an
op-ed that was published yesterday
in the union leader and my op-ed was in
response to one by
kelly ayotte and lamontagne
back in september now the two of them
were calling for
post-primary party unity which is a very
nice thing
and it's nice to hear coming from them
together but
party unity is not a magical thing that
happens automatically
it has prerequisites and one of those
prerequisites
is that the primary be a
valid and fair one that people the
voters
have confidence in and if you'll recall
in 2010
uh kelly ayotte beat lamontagne by a
mere
1 percentage point 38 to 37
there were two other candidates in the
in the primary bill benny
and jim bender who got far more
than the margin between ayotte and
lamontagne
so that was a classic case of vote
splitting and i know very well because i
was on the jim bender campaign
and all of our efforts did nothing
but shift the outcome from
llaman probably from la maintained ayat
as
how we expect um
so you could think this is a rare rare
occurrence
and i don't know how often boat
splitting happens to change elections
but uh you know it happened again to
kelly ayotte in 2016
with the spoiler uh aaron day but
quite often boat splitting is lurking in
the background
it's the threat of it so it's
discouraging candidates
from entering the race uh from tossing
their hat in the ring and now that's a
sad thing
uh but fortunately there is a simple
solution this
voting method that we're discussing
today approval voting
it has minimal cost and huge impact
i it was dismissed recently by speaker
as being a
only marginal improvement actually would
be a dramatic improvement
if you look at simulation performance
of the various alternative voting
methods approval voting has by far
the biggest impact for the cost all
other alternative methods exist that are
actually better
in the sense they produce better results
but they have a far greater cost in
complexity
that's voter instructions
error rates tabulation
recounting the ability to count the
votes centrally
or locally rather than centrally
so i'll just add this if
approval voting is not
it does not distinguish preferences
enough for you
you can upgrade it to what's called
score voting
where you rate the candidates not just
zero or one but
zero through five if necessary but
that's not what we're discussing today
today
we're discussing approval voting so
in terms of bang for the buck approval
voting is
a no-brainer and i highly encourage you
to support it
and uh i'll take any questions you might
have even though we're
close to lunchtime any questions from
any questions from committee members
attending remote representative
principal montgomery
thank you thank you mr club are you a
current
new hampshire resident no i left new
hampshire a few years ago i currently
live in berlin germany the other berlin
thank you any further questions from
committee managers in the room for
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for joining us thank you
um if there's anybody else in the
attendees who wants to speak in regards
to 505 if they could please raise their
hand
i'm not seeing anything so i'm going to
close the public hearing on 505 and open
the public hearing on the house bill
514.
514 is relative to batcom rotation
and we get to have our esteemed clerk
join us
at the table again to introduce house
bill
[Music]
excuse me i'm sorry to interrupt
representative wells i think you're
going to need to get a microphone
[Music]
thank you representatives
okay
okay so this bill is a request of the
secretary of state's office again
um this office the office feels that the
formula in rsa
656.5 it's just too complex
and they're going to propose an
amendment
the idea is to put each party columns
posted
an equal number of times as a fairness
issue
every 10 years after redistricting takes
place
the secretary of state's formula for
each column rotation
tries to have each column and elected
office in different positions
the secretary of state's office fields
by removing the complex sentence
in rsa 656 column 5
and adding in an amendment this will
thank you representative wells will you
be taking any questions
i think i'm going to defer to deputy
scamland
thank you deputy mckinley
hi madam chair uh members of the
committee i'm david scanlan deputy
secretary of state
uh here in support of house bill 514
and want to thank representative wells
for
sponsoring the legislation every 10
years
after the decennial census we are
recalculating the party column rotation
that
appears uh on our general election
ballots
there was a a court ruling
well over a decade ago after some
litigation
about candidate rotations on the ballot
and
party column rotations where the judge
ruled that as a matter of fairness
our ballot had to contain rotation
schemes
to make sure that each candidate in the
case of
uh the candidate listings or
party columns on the ballot had to be
rotated so that they would appear in the
first
second third and fourth if necessary
positions as equal a number of times as
is reasonably possible so there was a
piece of legislation that was filed that
kind of directed the secretary of
and before i get there i just want to
read
roman numeral 2 from rsa 5
656 colon 5 which says the
position of party columns shall be
rotated on the ballots used
so that each party column shall appear
thereon
to the extent practicable and
approximately equal number of times in
the first
last and each intermediate column
position across the state
uh without requiring more than one
unique column order or ballot format
for each town ward or unincorporated
place so
that means we don't break ballots up
within individual town or award
boundaries the ballot is the same
uh no matter who votes on it in a town
or city ward
um if we were just talking about the
party column rotations republican
democrat
other uh or libertarian or other third
party if there was one
uh it would be easy enough but the
the language in roman numeral three of
that same statute
goes on to say that each generic column
rotation plan shall be based on a
reasonably balanced rotation
of party columns within and across all
non-floaterial state representative
districts those being the smallest
representative districts
to which each voting place is
apportioned pursuant to part one
article two of the constitution
constitution
and then it says consideration shall
also be given
uh to reasonably minimize any obvious
substantial
and avoidable imbalances in party column
rotation within
senate districts so essentially what
that means is
that in the process of determining the
party column rotations
you don't want to create a situation
where in a senate district for example
uh all or most of the towns in that
senate district
end up being in rotation column number
one
the statute says that we have to sort
that out so that we can spread those
towns out as evenly as possible as well
and so then we get to the the sentence
that is in question
in this piece of legislation the average
deviation from equal rotation
for the first party column position
measured across
the state as a whole and based on
population
according to the last decennial federal
census
shall be as close to zero percent as is
practicable
but in no event greater than one percent
um
as it turned out in the last 10 years
we got much closer to zero percent than
we did to one percent
but it was a huge effort um it took
several weeks
to put in place i will admit that i
don't understand the formula on
how we got there and there's probably
only one or two people
that worked on that that
maybe could explain it to you in an
understandable way so
what we would like to do is come up with
a formula that is a little bit more
transparent
and easy to understand we think that
that is achieved by removing that
sentence
and giving us the flexibility to
comply with the intent of the statute
[Music]
in as reasonable you know a deviation as
is possible if the committee feels that
that
sentence still needs to be in there then
we would simply suggest that you
change the one percent to two or three
percent
and with that madam chair i'll be happy
to try and answer any questions
i'm glad that it's not critical that
this
legislation get passed this session uh
but it does
need to be addressed before next session
uh
at the same time that redistricting is
taking place
thank you questions from committee
members in the room representative
mcdonald
thank you madam chairman good morning
again i'm deputy
secretary of state stanley i'm just um
i i've confirmed with the host legal
counsel on this
because of the controversy over the
years of location
trying to column from the ballots you
think
you would make a reference for what
decision was that aikens versus
secretary of state was that the one you
were referring to or
uh that yes that would be that would be
the
lawsuit that ended up with a judge
ruling that we had to rotate
order of candidates and party columns if
we were to delete this
sentence do you have any constitutional
uh we don't uh the statute was
was actually uh uh
passed by cliff below who was one of the
plaintiffs
in the against uh case and there may
have been an additional case that
um that followed up after the aikens
case that required this
and so this was designed by a state
senator
uh according to the way that he felt
the rotations uh should take place
uh i believe that what we are proposing
is still in compliance with
uh you know constitutional requirements
and
would be consistent with what the court
ordered
thank you very much further questions
i'm sorry i'm having trouble hearing
again
yeah i just pam and if tech is listening
there has been a definite echo in this
room
from i believe the
sound system somehow and the testimony
from the witnesses has been muted
compared
or certainly a lower decibel and
everybody's agreeing it's not just my
hearing
um than it was prior to the break so
there is definitely still something
going on with the sound
all right i'm hearing you and and
writing things down
i'm sorry deputy scanlon you were saying
i was just saying i can hear you very
i'm not seeing any hands up i'm not
seeing anybody
all right thank you from is there
anybody in attendance
make any comments on this bill i don't
have anybody signed up to speak on
all right with that i'm going to close
the public hearing on hb
514 thank you very much
thank you everybody for participating i
believe that concludes our business
for today committee members
you should have received a legal notice